es un alivio para muchos animales
salvajes en panamá los residentes de
este albergue del bosque húmedo de
gamboa ubicado al norte de la capital de
panamá descansan con mayor paz más del
30% perezoso como el que tengo aquí
conmigo que es un huérfano uno de los
huérfanos ya tienen más de un año de
estar con nosotros
los segundos casos por ganar son aves
que se caen de los nidos diego ardillas
que secan los nidos las aves más comunes
son los búhos no tropical muchos llegan
enfermos o heridos rescatados por el
personal de la asociación panamericana
para la conservación desde el 2005 la
asociación declara en su página web
haber rehabilitado y liberado más de 5
mil animales salvajes facilitando
cuidados especializados y tratamientos
veterinarios para poder soltarnos de
nuevo a la vida salvaje la asociación en
colaboración con el ministerio de
ambiente también tratará de luchar en
contra del tráfico ilegal de animales
silvestres que azota el país
pero ambiente está haciendo un esfuerzo
tremendo a través todas las direcciones
regionales en las provincias
de ubicar a esto
ciudadanos nacionales y extranjeros que
se dedican a este ilícito en un delito
ambiental de contrabando con animales
pero el próximo proyecto de la
asociación es la creación de pasos
aéreos en los alrededores de las
carreteras que atraviesan zonas boscosas
una medida que asegura el libre
movimiento y garantiza la seguridad
animal en los bosques panameños